the median pay for chief executives at
big banks has grown from three million
dollars in two thousand nine to eleven
million dollars Jamie Dimon has been the
head of JPMorgan for almost a decade
last year he brought home 21.5 million
dollars in his contemporary at Morgan
Stanley James Gorman twenty four point
two million and most of that was in
stock options if you were to look at the
Bloomberg pay index the highest paid
executives in the financial sector are
not from the big banks over here William
foley executive chairman of fidelity
national one hundred and four point nine
million Mario gabelli of gamco eighty
eight point five million and Stephen
Schwarzman who heads the world's largest
private equity firm eighty five point
nine million dollars in fact of the
hundred highest paid executives last
year only two of them were bankers and
both of them work at the same firm Lloyd
Blankfein brought in 31.8 million and
Gary Cohn twenty nine point six million
dollars so who topped the list last year
well gopro's Nicholas Woodman's pay
package is worth two hundred and eighty
five point three million dollars and
something you have to keep in mind is
he's a founder of that company which
means he was paid a lot in equity number
two is Michael freeze the head of
Liberty global that's a big cable
company he pulled in a hundred and
thirty nine point nine million dollars
which got to keep in mind is that media
compensation tends to be very high let's
Moonves at CBS made fifty point eight
million dollars Bob Iger at Disney 50
1.4 million dollars of course most
executives say to make a lot of money
when they step down from running a
company Jack Welch the longtime head of
General Electric chairman and CEO got a
severance package worth 417 million
dollars which in today's dollars would
be worth well north of five hundred
million dollars